maybe you don't like think about all the
other things you got to do cuz you're
hyper focused on the one thing probably
and then I'm focused on the wrong thing
when I need to be focusing on the most
important thing yeah we definitely see
that here in the
office even in the video oh especially
in the video yeah he's like
[Music]
this welcome back to careful boys we are
afraid of everything today always always
afraid we're talking about what is
something that drives you crazy about
yourself oh [__] I how you did yeah a
lot really we're going to need
to stretch this out stretch out the
Taffy a little he that's the video it
was like oh that's a
lot I would have never have got gotten
that from you cuz I've always thought
you were a like Embrace myself person
like I love everything is that funny I
work against myself all the [__] time
man really okay so so obviously I got
mad ADHD right so like there'll be times
when I'm [__] like I'm rushing like
cuz I'm late or whatever and then I have
to go back in the house like five times
same same I mean like I know to prepare
better and then I every single time I
beat myself up cuz I'm like you [__]
idiot how can you forget the keys when
you need a the keys to get in your car
and then you go back and you're like how
can you forget the actual thing you're
mean the person for you're bringing them
over a shirt and then you show up with
no [__] shirt or whatever it is like
God dang it dude can you do that during
Co when you bringing doctor's masks you
forgot the
masks no that'll be hilarious though
yeah I think um do you think it's cuz
you hyperfocus I I know you hyperfocus
on things maybe you don't like think
about all the other things you got to do
cuz you're hyperfocus on the one thing
probably and then I'm focused on the
wrong thing when I need to be focusing
on the most important thing yeah we
definitely see that here in the office
[Laughter]
even in the video he's oh especially in
the video yeah he's like this he's right
here
dude dude Ken did the best impression of
Joe I've ever seen I've ever seen she
just was she had the axe and she just
was like looking down like this but she
was slumped over at such a like a like a
a 90°
angle
90° Joe slump yeah perfect and I catch
myself and I'm like [__] why am I like
this [__] I can't [__] control it
for real it's pretty good and that yeah
I guess that would be the milder version
of when but does that drive you crazy
about yourself or are you fine with it
that's the key word drive yourself crazy
yeah cuz it looks like you fine with it
I'll tell you what I'll tell you what my
thing my thing is sometimes like I
instead of like just taking the L on
something I [__] up on like with Nikki
or something I have to I have to oh yeah
with you yeah for sure with you take the
L you ad L when I Tak an L with you try
it just try it I've never Tak an L with
what does that mean all right um no like
I will I will start debating with her
instead of like just just being like yo
I'm [__] sorry [__] like you know
what I mean [__] sorry I'll hold you
down that's better yeah well like he
can't be like ah [__] up it's
something that I've been working on cuz
I know that I do that like reflexively
I'm like let's debate about it o I can't
wait to debate and you just like say
nothing you'd be filibus in just so you
could win and [__] just to win the
[__] you should practice here so that
you can practice at home yeah practice
doing what you know just taking the L
when you deserve it here yeah what's the
L that I'm going to take here all Steve
days sucks
dude super wait all St all the time so
the the the the only time JK even
blipped on the radar recently is thanks
to all Steve Day by the way but I guess
all Steve day sucks on the radar
everybody on YouTube talking about all
St ASD that's right that sounds like a
disease everybody talking about the
colen Bounder situation giving mad props
mad love to JK for
once why all Steve day finally
everyone's talking about JK and they're
not just taking dumps on us why all
Steve day I love the fact that we all
showed up as Steve that day too and then
everything that's up there on the
Internet is just all of us on track in
tracksuits dude watching people analyze
us like why are they wearing that and
they think it's serious as
[__] it is serious what are you talking
about D it's a [__] serious matter
very serious um also when that video
came out we're in there we're like they
didn't do anything illegal that dude
that was when we didn't know anything
about like the Trisha P's nude videos
getting sent to kids and [__] that none
of that came out it was so early yeah I
was just talking about like my
experience with these [__] and then
like this Adam kid's like like great
story about what what he went through
but people that are into it though they
know every [__] detail and if you
miss anything they're just like oh you
guys are so [__] stupid and they're
so up they're so current cuz it's like
an everyday evolving thing like these
guys are so [__] stupid what do you
mean nothing illegal happened I'm like
dude I we didn't know that [__] I say in
the video I don't know if they're doing
anything with kids cuz I didn't know
about that it was so early man dude just
take the L man take that L right take
that L Anthony you knew L take that L
dude you knew what they were sending
kids man you think you're too Petty
what's that you think you're too Petty
I'm too Petty I'm very Petty yeah I'm
very Petty but I like that the most
Petty guy out there it's one of the
things I like about myself is how
ridiculously Petty I am Petty [__] right
here yeah it's funny I like it so yeah
that's not something that drives me
crazy but overly debating I've
definitely done that to some at some
like some parties I've been at too where
like someone like wants to talk about
something I'll just [__] start
debating them how do you feel after
you're like [__] that was a waste of
time or like why did why did it go there
no what I do after is I debate them
again in my head for like the next 4
days yeah dude I'm ridiculous I'm but
you win though you [__] end up
winning no cuz I'm not satisfied with
the win I could have won harder I could
have
like it's it's like you nailed them into
the sand and you're like I could have
got them way deeper it's like what it's
like Bart being like I didn't hit a
PR
a he knows the lingo yeah yeah you know
I listen to it every now and then I has
another hyperfocusing on the wrong [__]
trait cuz then it is it is a problem
solving thing you're you're trying to
solve something and then at the end of
it like oh man that was a lot of wasted
time but you're problem solving you know
Nikki paid me a good compliment recently
though cuz she was like I was I was
talking to this guy who's dealing with
who's like dealing with a a griend of
his right and he's like debating her and
I was like this is what Steve used to do
a lot and now you don't do that and I
was like
wow I like I think I did recently but
thank you or maybe it's not as intense
as it used to be cuz she's scarred from
those mem yeah yeah she's like I had to
fight this [__] for 5 days
straight and he's been wrong for 5 days
and wrong for five days I've never been
wrong for 5 days don't look at me man
I've never been wrong for 5 days not in
a row I have a good off the record for
you later you're going to like it oh
[__] which one of the things that you
have is the most thing that drives you
crazy you got a lot yeah I do have a
lot
one of like definitely focus is one of
them like I really I hate I feel like a
special needs person with how I can't
focus on certain things sometimes where
I just feel like as soon as I start
doing one thing in a house do we all
just got ADHD I think bro it's a problem
we all just special needs yeah we're all
special needs we are the dumbest man on
Earth and you know I think that's a wide
I think that's a wide blanket term you
know um but I think that's one of them
that's that's the big one and then I I
think I have a pretty bad temper like I
snaap like Prett yeah I've never seen
you and like physically or
emotionally both what happens if I'm
crying and punching the wall at the same
time what happens then you have a bad
temper really yeah dude like certain
things what's like the biggest trigger
cuz I've never seen you piss um I'll
start punching stuff no way I can't even
imagine you being like that I'll start
slamming things yeah I can't see that
too what is the trigger is it family oh
it's it's feeling
like hopeless sometimes and you know you
don't do it very publicly huh you don't
do it very no I feel like such a little
[__] you do it in your you do it in
your room and you put the pillow in your
face and you go [__] what's wrong with
me like God and I'll look at myself in
the mirror and be like just [__]
relax like I'll have to do that some
sometimes it's actually a problem you go
little mirror for real when I'm in front
of it I'm I'm not going to walk there
you know what I mean but I'll just be
like [__] relax dude just breathe
like I have to actively have you ever
made a have youever made a hole in the
wall I punched a hole in my in Tiff's
desk in the desk yeah like we we got an
argument about something I forgot what
it was was it over the pugs no but even
even some of the pugs like when they
dude I'll talk I'll talk about that
after um but like I I me and Tiff we got
in I forgot what the argument was
something very stupid and she left the
house and I was like right when she left
I went boom and I slammed it as hard as
I could and I was like God damn it and I
was so pissed and then I was like [__]
she works on that
desk it's and it's not like it's a
strong desk so you made her a cup holder
dude essentially it's the perfect size
to put her cup was it from Ikea that's
probably it was Ikea and in the moment I
was like sming I put a [__] hole in
my thing but then you look at it you're
like I'm such a [__] like stop trying
to hit stuff like this is not a good
look like you just feel like such an
idiot after cuz she found it right I
tried to cover you my dumb ass tried to
covered up with like all her papers like
she would have [__]
known and then like it wasn't until like
months later she goes do you know what
happened to the desk I'll be like I have
no idea what you're talking about no I
told her I was like I thought I was like
maybe it was a
meteor do we check the ceiling I was
like babe you're not using coasters it's
your problem people like
oh Lun trap I tried to [__] cover it
oh you don't remember you were so drunk
[__] on cing the damage oh yeah you
headbutt of that babe you're going you
have a
problem so something like like that is I
think it's gotten better over the past
year and I think that stems into like
road rage stuff um but I feel like I'm
I'm getting a better handle on it it's
it's definitely not 100% but I think
it's are you better with are you better
with road rage nowadays yeah I've been
really trying to work on that what about
cyclists and they still [__] piss you
off you got a lot of testosterone you
know what I like to do I like to just
drive behind them and I just don't try
to pass them I just did you see and then
I wait I I try to be as patient as I can
I really do wow did you see the kids hit
the cyclist in Las Vegas oh that was
[__] up did you guys cover that nope
are we going to cover that today
probably should do it on patreon yeah
that was really sad wait someone a dude
it's bad it's bad it looked like GTA he
just they just drive up and then hit him
from the back and then he flips and dies
Tom JK news that's tragedy that's always
a good good idea well plus I really
don't like bikers so I had mixed
feelings yeah cuz in your head you're
like that's my Daydream kind of but when
you see it play out in real life you're
like that's [__] up actually that's
really f
sometimes your fantasy should remain a
fantasy exactly and that us do in GTA
that's why it's a good outlet but yeah
probably like it's good though my anger
huh you got anger problems yeah I really
try to bottle it up though you're really
good at bottling it I try to like you're
good at separating it at least cuz it's
not like it doesn't look like part of
you're good at deflecting all of it so
we don't even think that you're capable
of it I you know what that just pissed
me off now I'm see red cuz I used I used
to think I don't like this narrative bro
I'm not a deflector okay colen you're
the def deflector bro I'm calling you
out you're literally deflecting that
right now to Colleen you just sent it
Colleen's way yeah cuz she yeah we go
back and forth dude we're calling out
Colleen
again we should go train with Nick one
of these days because like you know here
it's like verbal communication yeah when
you train it's physical communication
and usually Nick is like pretty
levelheaded you know he's just the way
he is here but just through his body and
then there are times where I've seen
Nick turn it up and just start seeing
him light the [__] out of someone and
you're just like oh
[__] only you guys only have one like
come on come on it just starts [__]
lighting the full up like crazy like
come on start seeing everyone's desks
yeah just like oh whack them all yeah
and they're like oh [__] Nick can get
intense that's not true though no it's
very true I've heard stories about that
I'm excited to see that it's all the
same story it's one it's one story they
keep they keep spreading the I've seen
Nick whoop on I've seen you whoop on
David I've seen you whoop on I've never
I've never whooped on David I've never
whooped on Jason I've seen you whop on
Jason I've seen you even whoop on Cody
before is that a flex though are you
like I wasn't even going 10% no that's
a yeah that's a that's a straight up lie
dude that's not even true you call that
whooping that's not even true I'll show
you a whooping no that's not true at all
that's kind of f I'm a good training
partner I pride myself as being a good
training partner and I take care of my
buds dude after whooping on them
sometimes you got to whoop on somebody
Te You light up sometimes you see red
you don't know what happened yeah and
then there's a [__] giant hole in
their face oh my God
and like you did it to yourself oh one
time too I slammed the door really hard
and the frame came out the frame came
out the frame of the door yeah like you
know the side to like stop it from going
all the way through it came out and I
was like [__] dude it takes like four
cops in a battery Ram to do that no but
it was it's a real flimsy door it was
like it was stuck on by paint you know
like when they do that flimsy [__] it
was bad materials turn me on right now
but as soon as I did that you just feel
like such a [__] beta male you know
like you feel like such a little wuss
you don't feel strong though wow I for a
second but then you realize it's an Ikea
desk and it it took you 25 minutes to
put cuz we make fun of guys like that
all the time and it costs money and then
when you do that and it's your own
property too it's kind of and then you
yeah you just feel like a [__] and then
there's paint chips all over the floor
and I'm like [__] what idiot dude have
you ever punched something and then you
you afterwards you're like nobody's even
going to notice this cuz I'm such a
[__] yeah I waited for everyone to
leave the house no that happened to me
cuz I was this is a true story I was
leaving for um we were going to one of
the cons but I was running late cuz I
had to find couldn't find my [__]
mustache cuz I was doing internet
famous what the [__] oh dude that's when
you really need something you're looking
for it and I it was urgent cuz I have a
whole crew waiting on me and we're doing
we're just we're VidCon did us a favor
they let us shoot at VidCon for the and
this is the first scene of the whole
[__] movie like that we're filming
the whole time and and I and I couldn't
find my mustache anywhere and finally I
hauled off and I punched this cabinet
like over the sink in me and n's old
apartment I punched the cabinet and like
I was like man mustach mustaches fell
out bunch of mustaches it left a it left
a it left a crack in it right and I was
like man by the time we leave these guys
are going to be like yo it's like $7,000
property damage cuz like I wrecked that
cabinet so they never even [__]
noticed what you never
noticed I never noticed something like
that wood panel D It's hard you can't
see it it Blends in oh [__] that's what
a [__] punch did you find did you find
your mustache yeah I did I did was it
was on his eyebrows actually Nikki f it
was on my
face what about you
Andy I think it's nothing I think you
have nothing what are you talking about
I think he's perfect you're too tall I
keep hitting my head oh man if only I
was short wish I was be more average
okay W now you guys are making me feel
bad but my Gold's too bright dude I I
don't Dick's too strong body is too
fluid can you guys let me speak please
no we're gonna keep guessing anything
else 911 is Too
Fake it's a personal
trick and he hates it about himself he
doesn't like it about
himself take the L
Steve all right so
um yeah what about you B no your turn
dud do you actually have any though for
real no I think not deflecting dude sh
Colleen easy ni Nick um I think there's
there's this thing comes to mind that I
what I do hate is that when I get tired
there's no there's no coming back from
it mean sleepy you you don't rep perk
back up yeah if I get like sleepy or
something like that like if it's like a
kind of like how B is when he just shuts
off at 10: doesn't matter and he'll like
[__] kick his friends out even though
there's a party or something like that
it's kind of like that but he has more
of a reason cuz he like he starts
heading he has like a very thorough
schedule and exerts a lot of time and
it's like a father and does a lot of
things and activities and has two dogs
and like has a reason for me it's just
even if I was just awake watching TV the
whole day after a certain amount of
hours I get [__] tired your mood
turns it I'm I just can't like stay up
like the most intense things can be
happening and I'll be like
oh you know what I mean hard being that
sexy H Tak lot of energy it's very
difficult it pisses me off because like
sometimes drive me crazy cuz an
impromptu thing might come up like a
work thing that needs to be handled and
then I'll have to rely on somebody else
on the team to like help take care of it
because I'm like [__] I'm really tired
and what you do take a nap on set I can
like I have here oh yeah but that's
useful I that's I enjoy that about
myself I can go down for like 5 minutes
and come back and be like okay cool like
that that was helpful you think you
think that's a tall guy trait stupid
what tall guys go through they just get
tired all the time can you Google that
Steve ni asking one of his famous well
I'm asking the tall guys full NBA teams
are just laid out on the court dud you
ever see NBA players walk they're just
like
this you ever seen NBA players or just
athletes tall guys they walk so slow
dude little guys we got we just they
have a lot of blood to pump to their
dick too cuz of gravity yeah and then
the only other thing that bothers me is
they're lazy lovers I got like ass hairs
and stuff like that so if I don't have
like a wet wipe or like you know if I
don't like if it's like a sticky [__]
that driv you crazy yeah cuz then I'm
like dude just shave your [__] you
don't shave your [__] cuz I'm
conscious about and then I got go back
and like trim it you know what I mean
just shave your yeah shave your yeah I
know how do how do you do it again who's
the guy I subscribed to again I go like
this that's how I shave my assle it's
not perfect but you know what about
laser would you ever want to get lasered
on my [__] I'm going to need to do a
couple Consulting sessions because yeah
I you know what I heard it doesn't hurt
at all actually really I heard the laser
doesn't hurt on your butthole at all
when AI does it I'll do it if there's
humans around I'm not doing it comments
below please JK audience I'm like there
can't be anyone even in the parking lot
dude you can't look back there but you
know what they see so many [__] all
the time it's just it's not a thing yeah
it's always somebody's first day though
that's true but you don't share your own
[__] so many times so it is a thing
every time that's true it's special for
you yeah all right so what about you
Bart yeah what about you Bart I think
for me it's something I've been working
on my whole life and it's way better but
I I as a kid I had really crazy
OCD like if I uh didn't close the door
the right way I would have to go back
inside and redo it really yeah there's
like like or if I like let's say um so
like my best friend that I got the
original tattoo with he knew I had this
OCD so I have to no this is the original
Dude yourself so one of the things that
this one you mean so one of the things
that I had to do was um [__] I forgot
now cuz I cuz I cured this of myself but
I forgot what it was but there's a
certain way I would shower and I forgot
if it was soap first and then shampoo
after or whatever but I would uh be in
the shower and he would know like what
I'm doing so he'll [__] it all up come
in the bathroom and just squirt like
shampoo on my head I'm like [__] so I
have to go back in rinse everything and
then start all over oh and it's so bad
to the point where in boot camp where
we're already sleeping only 4 hours a
night right cuz it's the whole day
you're [__] training everyone's
covered in mud [__] camel paint and
[__] and you're sleeping and you don't
really have personal time I would try to
stay awake until like everyone knocks
out and then I would sneakily go into
the bathroom and then do my own shower
just or else I'll have this itch that I
can't [__] scratch and'll bug me like
a [__] so now I don't have it
anymore but that's one of the many
things yeah that I'll do so like even
now like before I answer emails I have
to take a shower
I have to I have to be like um I have to
present myself in the best shape
digitally yeah yeah yeah because he's
got to be professional interesting yeah
it's weird it's almost like if I don't
I'm I'm I'm answering emails as a rap so
I'm not going to be able to critically
think or do anything you know but then
if I if I shower and I do all my [__]
then when I go I'm like cool this is
[__] like boss man Bart CEO Bart blah
blah blah blah blah BL where do you
think those rules came up from I don't
know it's it's been like that since I
was a kid I have all these like [__]
little weird things transition and it
drives me crazy cuz it's not convenient
at all yo I you answer this email right
now and I'm like [__] [__] [__] damn
why can't you give me 30 minutes you
know it's like like like that's not
more so that [__] drives me crazy cuz
I'm like why do I have to do all this
[__] preparation to [__] do [__]
is that why always showering no I'm
surprised you don't have a shower here
we used to have a shower in the office
he has a outdoor shower at behind the
gym like we just showed outside today
yeah we sh we shout outside lionhardt
today we have a hose and he's like can I
shower can I shower and I was like yeah
dude we can shower [__] relax but
that's one of the many like another
thing would be like if I'm eating and I
order a set meal like let's say like
burgers fries and a drink it has to go
all down at the same
time so if I have this many fries and
this much drink left I'll
go until it's like the end and then it's
like it has to finish I think I have the
same thing but just way my have a lot of
weird random [__] and that that's not
inconvenience so does it matter yeah
that's why you think I have
zero but then there's times where it
does drive me crazy cuz it's I'm like
what the [__] like why does it have why
do I have to do it this way dang yeah
but as a kid it was [__]
as a kid it was like I had that same
thing with even numbers yeah even
numbers even numbers when I was like
growing up like if I if I picked this up
and I put it down I'd be
like like two times two times wa or if I
had to do something five times I had to
do it six like as a kid all I couldn't I
could not leave the thing alone yeah I
always have to count when I pee count I
always count when I pee because if it's
if I'm not if I'm peeing and it's not 30
seconds it was a waste of time
a waste of time dude you guys are
[__] freak so you're like I could
have held it longer yeah oh wow that's
some [__] as that's some Asian [__]
dude very efficient and the volume knob
on the radio always has to be a multiple
of five yeah damn I can't even hold my
pee and poop these days anymore mple of
five what does that mean I was up with M
I'm always wasting time you try to know
I just go just do it on all Steve day
back then what but like a a year or two
ago I'd be like oh I got a pee and then
I probably got like 15 minutes I'm like
a child now if I'm like oh I got a pee
I'm like I got to pee and then I just
have to pull over the road and go I got
like [__] got to PE like on the 405
yeah pop Joe yeah like I was I was going
to Vegas and then I was like ooh I got
to pee right and I was like oh there's
probably going to be a gas station and
I'm like Oh no I got less than three
minutes right here and I'm like oh
there's a [__] rest stop so I pulled
over to the rest stop and there was a
line of trucks like those big rigs so I
was like I'm not making to the bathroom
so I just pulled up to the dirt parking
lot next to a truck ran out and pissed
on a rock nice well everybody was going
to the SI I'm always doing in between
the rest on the road in between
them I barely fixed this thing about me
it's maybe in the past couple years the
uh I couldn't take a [__] in public
anywhere like uh public restrooms how do
you travel the world so the the crazy
thing is like when I was in seventh
grade I went to Camp like a surf camp
with my school it was 5 days long and I
was like a legend for not [__] you
didn't [__] for 5 days well how did
everyone know that you did cuz everyone
knows I have that thing all my friends
know that I can't take a [__] in like a
public restroom so wait you're walking
around you're like The Legend Continues
today 3 days count yeah because they saw
me I wasn't eating anything because I
didn't want [__] so I just ate like Kit
Kat like a bar of it like every now and
then and I wasn't eating the real food
cuz it's I had like a phobia I was like
I couldn't use like public toilets did
you think you going to get AIDS by
shitty get a public I thought I was
going to get AIDS I wouldn't go to sixth
grade Camp cuz I was afraid that I
couldn't shower there and and and if I
would have like could I shower every day
I was like [__] that cuz I I I was just
a kid with acne and [__] and I was so
scared of like making my skin worse or
whatever yeah yeah the condition so I
missed out on a lot of great stuff hey
so when you poop in public now now do
you feel like man I [__] did dudee I
actually kind of feel cool yeah you cuz
like I also not only that but like I
always I would have to take off all my
clothes to take a
[__] that's reasonable that's reasonable
I think Tim ghetto does that too the wor
yeah it's the worst because like
sometimes there's been like very like
few times I've been walked in on like
that and it's so funny he's butt ass
naked or like someone sees me through
the
crack my God even in public yeah even
like dude yeah I have to like I got to
do it dud all right this room needs
[Laughter]
therapy